conduire une voiture électrique c'est
loin d'être compliqué pour Benoît
charrette quand on achète un véhicule
électrique moi je suis toujours aux gens
il faut penser comme quand on a iPhone
quand on a un iPad c'est à dire que il
faut penser brancher son véhicule
régulièrement même si en hiver le
véhicule peut perdre jusqu'à 40 % de
l'autonomie
[Musique]
c'est parti là on est dans le 150
Lightning que la grosse batterie c'est à
dire 131 kW la petite batterie fait 98
kilowatts le chroniqueur automobile de
30 ans d'expérience recommande aux
conducteurs inquiets de tomber en panne
de mieux planifier leur trajet et de
cibler au départ les bornes électriques
sur leur chemin recharger un véhicule
électrique c'est plus long donc sur la
route il va falloir trouver une charge
de niveau 3 si on veut pas passer à jour
mais là dépendamment de ce qui reste
d'énergie on recommande toujours de
remplir en 10 et 80%. selon lui pour
accélérer le virage vers la voiture
électrique Hydro-Québec doit implanter
plus de bornes à recharge rapide des
bornes de niveau 3 par ces bornes de
niveau 2 c'est bien si on voit quelque
part et on couche là parce que ça prend
8 9 10 12 heures avec l'électrification
des transports Hydro-Québec dit déployer
entre 150 et 180 nouvelles bornes
rapides par année on va atteindre 2500
bornes rapides si 2030 et on est
également mis en place un programme pour
financer 4500 nouvelles bornes de niveau
2 dans les municipalités donc des bornes
sur rue c'est un objectif pour beaucoup
de gens de pouvoir faire Montréal Québec
aller-retour dans un avenir rapproché
Benoît charrette est convaincu que la
voiture électrique sera intéressée
davantage de conducteurs avec une
batterie plus performante la technologie
va faire en sorte qu'on va arriver assez
rapidement dans les prochaines années
kilomètres on annonce même 1000 km
d'autonomie alors une fois qu'on sera
rendu là il y a vraiment plus de raison
de dire ben c'est pas pour moi le
véhicule électrique pour l'instant les
véhicules électriques ne représentent
que 5% des nouvelles immatriculations de
voitures au Canada ce qui est bien en
deçà de l'objectif du gouvernement
fédéral soit une nouvelle
immatriculation ou sur deux d'ici 2030
et la totalité d'ici 2035 ici Gabriel
prout Radio-Canada Montréal